reuters et la bbc sont des groupes
mondialement connu il revendique
professionnalisme et indépendance
éditoriale mais des révélations pourrait
bien ternir cette image
les fuites de documents ont émergé ces
derniers jours et sont compilés dans un
article du site d'investigation
américain green zone
dans une démonstration détaillée et
appuyé par des extraits d' échanges de
mails et de documents le site montre les
relations entre le ministère des
affaires étrangères britannique et des
organismes tels que la bbc ou reuters
les nouvelles fuites illustre avec des
détails alarmant comment reuters et la
bbc2 des groupes de presse les plus
importants les plus distingués au monde
ont tenté de répondre à l'appel à l'aide
du ministère des affaires étrangères
britannique pour améliorer sa capacité à
répondre et promouvoir notre message à
travers la russie et pour contrer le
discours du gouvernement russe ayant
pour but de lutter contre ce qui est
présenté comme l influence russe le
ministère des affaires étrangères
britannique s'est appuyé sur le réseau
et les connaissances de ces deux
entreprises au sein d'un département du
ministère luttant contre la
désinformation des projets ont vu le
jour pour parvenir à un certain nombre
d'objectifs
il ya par exemple ces programmes de
formation menées en russie grâce à des
programmes de formation de journalistes
russes supervisé par reuters le
ministère des affaires étrangères
britannique a cherché à produire un
changement d'attitude chez les
participants favorisant un impact
positif sur leur perception du royaume
uni parmi les autres opérations révélé
grâce à ces fuites ces deux documents le
soutien apporté à des médias présenté
comme indépendant dans des pays proches
de la russie
le but là encore était de contrer
l'influencé russe en faisant émerger par
exemple des voix pro otan dans un
certain nombre de documents dévoilés on
peut lire les mentions appelant à une
stricte confidentialité des échanges
il faut dire que ces manoeuvres secrètes
ont nécessité de l'argent public
britannique
parmi les entités concernées par ces
échanges que nous avons contacté seul
reuters nous a répondu à l'heure où nous
enregistrons cette chronique
l'entreprise ne nie pas la véracité des
documents publiés mais souligne
indépendant entre l' agence de presse et
la thomson reuters foundation cité dans
les échanges et qui serait je cite une
entité légale m'en séparer du pôle
éditorial
ce financement soutient notre travail
indépendant pour aider les journalistes
et le journalisme dans le monde entier
dans le cadre de notre mission de
renforcement d'un éco système médiatique
mondiale libre et dynamique pour
soutenir une pluralité de voix et
préserver le flux d'informations
précises et indépendante
en effet une couverture médiatique
précise et équilibrée est un pilier
essentiel de toute société libre juste
et informer circulez il n'ya rien à voir
reste que le nom reuters reste associé
dans l'esprit du grand public à la
célèbre agence de presse
la version selon laquelle reuters et la
bbc n'aurait agi que par philanthropie
ne convainc pas tout le monde à
commencer par la diplomatie russe
il existe des centaines de documents qui
dévoile la machine de propagande de
londres nous les lisons avec une grande
attention et nous attendons la réaction
de londres et si tout cela n'était qu'un
mensonge
il faudrait tout de même se prononcer là
dessus car des millions de livres ont
été gaspillés pour le financement de ses
campagnes d'informations secrètes
l' affaire est embarrassante car elle
met en lumière des agissements obscur
que les gouvernements occidentaux
attribue volontiers à moscou à la
moindre occasion un jeu d'influencés
servi par des médias dont on pourrait
penser à la lecture de ces fuites qui ne
sont finalement pas si irréprochable